okay so what is the solution to cancel
culture
this is it i'll tell you what it is i've
told you this before
i'll say it again i'll keep saying it um
the only way to stop canceled culture
the only way to stop the mob
is to never apologize to it to give it
nothing
to make no concessions to offend it
on purpose just out of principle
and to laugh in its face that's it
that's the solution there is no other
solution
if you don't like that solution okay
well but that's the only one there isn't
another one
this is a battle of wills this is one
side
trying to impose itself
exercise its power punish dissent
get vengeance revenge
you don't deal with people like that who
have those kinds of intentions
by being polite and saying now guys i i
understand where you're coming from and
your concerns are so legitimate and
important
and uh and and before i say anything
else here are a number of issues i agree
with you on in fact i agree with you on
almost everything when it comes down to
it because you're using
you're very brilliant and insightful
people and i just like but
i i wouldn't say anything about you that
would be personally critical and i i
care so much about your feelings your
feelings are so important to me
on such a such a deep and and visceral
level
uh but now that i've said all that can i
please allow me to present an argument
explaining why from my perspective
blah blah blah blah blah no
that what do you think that's going to
achieve
they aren't interested in that they
don't care
they want you to get to the cut to the
chase are you going to bow
bend the knee surrender give up or not
that's all they care about your choices
are either to do what they want
or not and if not then defiance
resilience and firmness
uh are the only other options
you beat an opponent by taking away
whatever power
it has over you you have to neutralize
it
there can't be any here's the other
thing about well why can't we have
compromise
and discussion
you're not going to compromise with
someone they're not going to compromise
with you
if they think they can get everything
they want anyway
compromise only happens when both
parties involved in the compromise
realize that they're not going to get
everything they want
and so they have no choice but to
compromise
a compromise that someone does
or agrees to when they don't have to
because they could get everything they
want that's not a compromise that's
charity and if you're looking for
charity from the canceled culture mob
then you're really stupid
um but a compromise is something that if
they
if they're not if a if an opponent
doesn't matter
whether we're on a battlefield or
negotiating a salary
in your boss's office whatever it is
there's only going to be a compromise or
negotiation if
the person you're dealing with realizes
they're not going gonna get everything
they want
if you've made it clear that they if
you've made it clear to them that they
can get everything they want
why they're not gonna compromise with
why should they
as long as the opponent has power over
you it will achieve victory after
victory it will never compromise
because there's no reason to
why compromise when you can have an
unconditional surrender instead
why take only some when you can have
everything
so that's why you have to take away the
power
how do you take away power from the
canceled culture mob well by
neutralizing its weapon
and its weapon is primarily emotional
the mob says it feels deeply hurt deeply
offended terribly injured
by whatever opinion or idea you
expressed
um and they they they need all kinds of
things to be done to make them feel
better
it's nonsense of course it's nothing but
a ploy it's manipulation it's blackmail
but most of the time the targets of this
manipulation will say oh i'm so sorry i
made you feel that way please don't be
mad at me
please don't be mad at me i'm so so
sorry
no the way you neutralize that weapon
take away that power
is by saying i don't care how you feel i
don't apologize to you
your feelings are irrelevant to me i
don't care if you have ptsd for the rest
of your life because of what i said
i'll sleep like a baby tonight anyway in
fact i'll laugh at you
i'm happy about it i'm happy i upset you
i don't care about your feelings and i'm
not going to explain myself either
don't like what i said deal with it it's
your problem it's not mine
now get the hell out of my face
now of course if only a few people are
dealing with the mob this way then the
mob will be able to continue on
basically unimpeded it will often
probably be able to punish those few
dissenters
punish them for their defiance by taking
away their job their livelihood and
whatever else
that's the way it always goes if only a
few people have the guts to stand up
to a bully then uh you know they're
especially when they're so outnumbered
then then
they're gonna pay a price for that but
um
there always have to be some people who
will
who will uh you know lead by example
if enough people deal with the mob like
this
then they'll be defeated because that's
the thing
they only have the power we give them
when someone is using emotional
blackmail it's
it's only it's it's not like they're
using
physical weapons well in fact the mob is
using physical weapons
increasingly so and and the more that
they're emboldened the more
they will do so but most of the time
when we're talking about cancel culture
it's a weapon that has to be given to
them it's an emotional weapon
emotional blackmail
if you don't care about their feelings
if enough people don't care about their
feelings
then they got nowhere else to go all
they can do is put their tail between
their legs
and and go home and shut up
that's the only solution this video is
sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description